all right he's the man everyone's
talking about Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis now you might call him Governor
turn around because it wasn't so many
years ago that Democrats were bragging
that they were on the verge of turning
the Sunshine State blue
but now after four years of DeSantis and
his policies it's a reliable Republican
stronghold he won re-election by 20
points and with his success comes a lot
of presidential Buzz joining me now is
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis author of
the brand new book I'm holding it my
hand the courage to be free Florida's
blueprint for America's Revival gov
you've been doing the rounds man you
tired yet
um it's good it's good to see you well
so you know I really appreciate
everybody uh chipping in well um we know
that the buzz about you is because of
your success in Florida and that's what
everyone says and that's what people
want to replicate on the national scale
but there's criticism of your book that
it's there's a lot of policy but there's
not enough you and there's a lot of
success in Florida but they want to hear
more about you you on China you on trade
you on you know these substantive issues
of foreign policy what of that
well I mean Laura I actually do address
some of that I mean of course I'm a
governor so the the issues that I'm
dealing with over the last four years
were things like covet education the
economy and all the core things
Governors deal with but what we have
done in Florida is take on the CCP so
we've eliminated things like Confucius
institutes from universities and we're
getting ready to enact in the law a ban
on CCP linked businesses purchasing land
in Florida and we've worked with the
Taiwanese here in Florida to be able to
advance that so we've been able to do
stuff to make an impact on the state
level but look at the end of the day
what I was trying to do was identify
kind of how we LED because I think there
are certain principles of leadership
that allowed us to get accomplished so
much stuff but then also just show
people it can be done nobody faced more
resistance and attacks from the left in
the media of any 50 state Governors than
and me over the last four years not only
were able to overcome that but we were
actually able to win a historic
Landslide reelection now Biden spoke at
the house Democratic caucus tonight
their issues conference and he made a
comment in you know about passing
left-wing pet issues with help from the
Republican Party
the Maga Republicans are not going to
get on board for most of these things
but that leaves a lot of Republicans
that are still left
no by the way watch
watch I predict watch Watch What Happens
Republicans can help make a significant
majority in some of these things
yeah because seven trillion dollars in
spending is not enough apparently now
alarmingly Governor most Republican
Senators and Leadership seem to be a lot
closer to Liz Cheney than to perhaps you
and and former president Trump on the
issue so do you consider that a problem
in a disconnect between the electorate
and the leadership
well it's a disconnect from the the base
of the Republican Party in the
conservative Grassroots but I think it's
a disconnect with the majority of the
public I mean the fact of the matter is
Biden's policies have failed a clear
majority of people believe they failed a
clear majority of people believe the
country's on the wrong track so I think
the proper posture is to fight back
against Biden and then offer an
alternative Vision that that vast
majority of the public may want to sign
up for
so Illinois and Michigan governor
pritzker governor Whitmer they're
oftentimes mentioned as possible future
presidential candidates if Biden doesn't
run or something like that now to a lot
of us the fact that they were re-elected
we get why you were re-elected but they
were re-elected by healthy margins so
what are the people of Michigan and
Illinois missing that your voters seem
to get in the analysis
well Laura I mean some of these races I
mean you know you have the governor of
Illinois he had unlimited resources our
candidate didn't so I think there's some
other factors there all I can tell you
is you don't have very many people
moving from Florida to Illinois and to
Michigan but I run into people every day
who've moved to Florida from Illinois
and from Michigan and the way we govern
the state and the principles that we
uphold is a big reason why you look I
know Illinois is hemorrhaged more people
than just about any state other than
California and New York over the last
three or four years and there's a reason
for that they're not keeping the streets
safe they're taxing people too much
they're trying to put indoctrination in
the schools in Florida we stand on the
opposite side of all those issues and
the good thing about a federalist system
with 50 states people can vote with
their feet and they voted for the free
state of Florida
and Governor I know you and some other
notable Republicans are speaking at a
Club for Growth conference this weekend
and apparently apparently that
appearance is being used by Psalm
including president Trump against you
and he basically says failed former
Congressman David McIntosh and his
globalist friends at club for no growth
who fought me all the way in 2016 and
lost and then fought me again in 2020
are now threatening to spend money
against me early because they're new you
know it calls you boy Ron Des Sanctus
um Governor I know you're not going to
talk about whether you're going to run
for president but the Club for Growth is
known to be very pro-china trade very
liberal on issues like immigration those
key issues which are bread and butter
for the America First more populous
conservatives uh would you be someone
who would be co-opted because they worry
about from The Establishment forces
well in Florida I came in and what one
of the first things I did I got a ban on
Sanctuary cities through the legislature
of course I've transported illegal
aliens to Martha's Vineyard we're now
working on mandatory e-verify in the
State of Florida uh and also when I was
in Congress we opposed the gang of Aid
amnesty back in 2013 which would have
been a disaster uh so no I mean I think
my record is very very clear and we are
going to be strong on immigration and
we're going to be very strong against
China and it's not just because that's
what the base wants those are the proper
policies given what we're facing in this
country an open border and China that
gets away with murder across our
economic relationship they're flying a
balloon to spy on Americans over the
continental United States we need to be
smarter we need to be stronger
Governor that means you're not for the
trans-pacific partnership going back to
that old horse are you
no no I mean I think that what we need
to do is we need to disaggregate the
economic relationship with China we need
to recapture Supply chains here in the
United States I think there could be
some economic benefits for people here
at home but I think just as importantly
this is a security issue uh they are in
control of key things that our economy
depends on and this has been something
that's happened over a quarter Century I
think starting with them going into the
WTO but the reality is there's an
imbalance in the relationship that's not
good for U.S interests governor
is destined to be number one I think
it's the fastest selling book I
understand of a sitting political figure
and huge hit we wish you all the luck on
the book tour and go teach those Club
for Growth people something we
appreciate you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else